but I think compatibility is so
important so would you tell a young
woman to sleep around and like explore
their sexuality or would you tell them
to keep your body count as low as
possible so you can get the best quality
husband
um I would say what what is important to
you and some people that's it some
people some people sleep around for
validation and they'd be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like I have had
casual sex because I enjoy sex that's
that's the right long and short of it I
enjoy sex
um female sexual Liberation I'm all here
for it yeah um but I used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and I got to a
point in like late 2020 where I was like
I don't want to do that anymore because
I've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and I ended up in
relationships where I thought the men
were my league but they didn't respect
me so then I dated men who were under my
league who adored me then I was like
you're not enough well do you yeah do
you think maybe they were actually your
league because like you can't say that
someone was your league if they weren't
able to commit to you like your league
is who you can get to commit to you but
then this comes to the success and
ambition and blah blah blah right but
remember men and women are valued for
different things yeah so so I settled
for men that were short and broke I
settle for men but they could say like
they settled for you with a high body
count but they could they could say the
same thing but they are men that
literally the men that I settled for
were men that literally were like they
look at me in the morning and be like
beautiful person in the world and I was
like no I'm not you're incorrect I you I
was like you literally you expect too
too little
Behavior
Behavior yeah like yeah I was gonna say
I think there is a I think there is a
middle yeah between
um between
uh a girl getting a guy because I get
what you're saying yeah like for for
girls your league isn't who you can
sleep with your league is who you can
get to commit who can get to commit to
you but what I would say is that a lot
of girls date guys who could have
committed to them but because they've
dated them in a certain way they've put
themselves in the friends with benefit
zone so now that's not on the table does
that make sense so I think there is like
you know oh for sure like there is like
a you know like oh if a guy is a nine
and he's sleeping with a girl who's
quoting quite a five that she's probably
never gonna commit to her right but it's
possible that okay for guys in eight who
gets a lot of attention he may sleep
with a girl as an A but if she plays it
wrong you might think oh she's hot
like she's very attractive I think that
she's not girlfriend I think guys go
down and looks all the time I'm not like
just sex yeah I'm not discounting that
but I'm saying like as a girl it's still
what you can get to commit because
that's still you it's your it's your
choices yeah right it's true but I think
I think girls don't um I think a lot of
girls
due date guys who could have committed
to them it's just because the way they
dated him the guy was like well she's
not go for material yeah and then this
does come back to body count because
I've had an experience where recently a
guy is like well I've not dated anyone
since you I get a bit jealous when you
tell me you want to end things and I'm
like but you've told me you're not going
to commit to me you're not gonna be
serious about me I'm never gonna be your
girlfriend I'm like but you are serious
about me and to be fair body count
doesn't actually relate to our situation
but oh there's just so many like really
like intricate details and it's not it's
not necessarily like practical in this
day and age right because again the
average age of first marriage is 27 like
guys used to marry virgins and now like
guys don't even like want virgins yeah
but that's it it's that whole so it's
all black and white situation where a
guy you know a lot of it's about ego and
a lot of it a lot of it is about
people's self-worth and self-esteem and
I did have a really good point to say
and it's about attractiveness even that
so I used to go off of the ethos to a
blind person we all look the same so I
gave a lot of people chances and I used
to go on dates with anyone because I
just don't do that I'm like don't don't
do it this sounds so awful but like so I
did that I was like talking to give them
pity sex like I used to pick it I didn't
say that I used to pick not I used to
pity kiss people I give people my phone
number and be like I don't really want
to give you my phone but maybe if you're
showing me interest and they're going so
this is what I say undervalued or
underwhelmed yeah so that was what I
ended up in I used to be like
guys that I thought were like my level
my league would like not value me and
then guys that were who really adored me
like loved me really valued me I was
like oh you're underwhelming I don't
think like you match up and that's why
I've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because I'm like I don't
want to get hurt I I don't want to hurt
anyone but I don't get hurt and I was
like I'm actually we're also you're
gonna be like being alone you're also
competing for a small percentage of guys
too that you're probably attracted yeah
you know that only like 10 I don't even
I don't know the exact stat but I've
heard numbers from five to fifteen
percent of dating app swipes or I don't
use dating apps
no and it's because dating apps do tend
to be a black and white party in that
you've either got people on there who
are like I just want something casual
nice not nothing serious
um or you've got people who are like I'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like I want a
relationship Ergo I am looking for
someone who can fill that criteria so
when they go on dates when they swipe
they're like I'm literally thinking
about are you going through your
relationship with material or
there's people like me I'm bottom up
where I'm like I'd rather just meet
someone and be like where is this gonna
go let's live in the now let's take it
date by date time by time women it would
be better for women if we dated more
intentionally because to me it's like if
you could be single you could be single
let's say you're single for five years
you're in a relationship for five years
like I would think that the girl would
probably be less like
heartbroken and have less trauma if she
was in a relationship for five years it
depends because I mean Assuming he's not
narcissist assuming there's no abuse
narcissists like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like I don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like like you know what I'm saying like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time
investor is subjective like Eat Pray
Love is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful
she's like I'm actually not happy I'm
actually not like to Circle back with
that lady yeah
yeah and it's like that was it there are
there are people who sometimes wake up
and go [ __ ] I'm not happy and I should
be happy yeah I hate the concept of
should and so I'm I'm a really big
advocate for like difference do you
think happiness like comes and goes oh
yeah like like do you think you should
just leave a relation a relationship
with like kids and stuff if you're not
happy so I was gonna I was gonna say
would you here's a question would you
sacrifice happiness for fulfillment
yeah
would you because I think happened like
you say happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled with
what you have but would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
then it depends like for me happiness
probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent upon fulfillment but I'm
obviously like we could die tomorrow and
if you're not happy and if you're not
like content if you're not if you're not
a whole individual
than anything else that you like put
yourself into like
I don't know it's a really tough that's
it nothing is ever black that's it going
back to nothing is black and white right
or wrong Better or Worse
um nothing's right or wrong but like
it's that gray area of like in some
situations I'd probably be like I'll
sacrifice happiness like even when you
study or you do a job if you do a job
that's interesting I think if you ask
men the same question most of them would
say yes I think women care a lot more
about being happy and Men care a lot
more about being fulfilled well that's
like because I think I think it's not
about like you especially if you have a
family it's not about you anymore like
doesn't she leave does she leave a
husband and kids and Eat Pray Love uh
she leaves her husband
a husband and a job yeah like I don't
know I think that's that's a bit selfish
you're leaving a commitment you made for
what to go like go to India but to be
selfish means that we're prioritizing
what everyone else wants compared to
what we want yeah but sometimes what you
want isn't right like emotions come and
go people leave like that's it right and
wrong very subjective that's it's all
about that gray area walking the middle
path right and wrong to one person so
that's it genocide and racism to one
person is right uh-huh like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue into your blue in the face
and be like that's not correct and they
literally be like like that's it Hitler
Hitler literally what is she it's it's
like right I think there's consequences
and I I'd really like to Circle back
with that later yeah maybe she made a
book she made a lot of money it might
have worked out yeah yeah
so you know what I mean maybe she did
but I don't think the average woman that
makes that decision it's gonna end up
well for her no no not until and that's
why you've got to be cognizant of
differences and privileges yeah uh
circumstances and things like that so
yeah the average woman could not be like
I'm not happy in my job or my marriage
or being a mum yeah because then you're
like well [ __ ] finances your your
marriage your family like your kids and
the average woman could not do that
um but it doesn't mean that she
shouldn't want to or she like it's just
like oh but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living for expectations I think it's
okay
to live for others and I'll give you an
example okay yeah I live a lot for my
dad's approval like a lot I care a lot
what my dad thinks like a lot and I do a
lot of things not because I want to but
because he wants me to and I don't mean
like like I would I'm doing this clearly
because I love this yeah he doesn't care
about social media but just in terms of
like like my last boyfriend my dad
didn't like and that really bothered me
it bothered me a lot because I love my
dad and I think like there's some things
it's okay it's almost a good thing to
like put you know values and like your
commitments and like your word above
what makes you happy at the time yeah I
I was gonna say I think the difference
between people today and people back in
the day is that we back in the day
people were all about Community yeah it
was all about doing what's best for the
community it was all about doing what's
best for your family was now I think
I think back then we didn't have enough
individualism that people were
sacrificing a lot of their happiness for
their Community but now we've gone the
other way where there's so much
individualism now yeah that people are
no longer contributing or even care
about their local community or their
family and their nuclear family which is
why people leave
etc etc so I I agree and you know I'm my
family Nigerian and in our culture like
once you have kids it's about them you
do what's best for them so if you but
you staying with your partner is what's
best for the kids and you can make that
work that's what you do until they leave
then you split up or whatever actually I
always say people always ask me if I'd
stay with the cheater and I always say
no unless there were kids
um interesting why do you say that
because if they're kids it's not about
me
how about you
um I mean I've I've stayed with Jesus
I've stayed with Jesus and I know a lot
of that is actually based upon my
self-worth and being like you know XYZ
and I'd love to say no I know I deserve
better and no no but yeah if there's
kids it's a whole different Ballpark and
if you're it depends on how selfish
yourself because being selfish isn't a
bad thing because if you're like what
I'm living for others then when do you
live for you because
and it oh it really depends on like so a
lot of people love honor and pride we
don't think being selfish is a bad thing
so no no so you say you live for your
dad's approval my dad's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] my family we
are not close at all my mum actually had
been like me like right and so I'm like
if I'm not living for me and during my
life I could be dead tomorrow and if I
knew that I lived for everyone else I'm
living for their approval or my
well-being and my quality of life is
dependent upon how they feel towards me
yeah and if that's it it's not black and
white it's very much like
the people I love know that I love them
the people I love I'm I'm very much a I
want you to feel loved I want you but
then I'm like
I've done a lot of therapy and so
they're like hey Amy you could only feel
good about yourself when you think
others feel good about you and they're
like that's really
so your self-worth is dependent upon the
approval of others I think that's normal
well if everyone hates you there's
probably a reason well
as far as I'm aware no one's ever hated
me but I've been so I stayed with the
cheetah because yeah I've stayed with
many cheaters and I I've been in a
relationship that it was the most toxic
thing that I've ever imagined that
everyone in my life is like we don't he
still talks to me and I still haven't we
broke up three four years ago we still
have an open communication path because
I can't block people because I'm like I
feel really bad if I block them even if
they're toxic for me and they're worse I
can't vote them I can't I can't do it
that's it I can't do it and everyone is
like Amy like are you are you confused
this person was awful to you
disrespected you and you still feel the
need to be good for them good for their
approval and I'm just like ah because it
makes you feel like a bad person I
bought people like oh